[Musique]
tu sais que tu danses bien là bon c'est
oui ça dans le sang avait abaissé sa tu
as un oiseau de couleur résidence bien à
moi j'adore c'est pour ce soir à tous
nos sources avancent pas bon avoir
gentiment un bon score avec le sourire
oui et bien la moindre des choses
1 qu'est ce que tu as préparé là je vois
sur le côté de l'établi argy préparer
celle de ses dérivés est un peu
difficile
ah oui il faut être très méticuleux
aujourd'hui pour faire ce petit celle
d'une amusante garde toute attente c'est
un appareil de photo tard exactement
alors je tendais par les noms mais je
n'ai pas le temps n'est pas parce qu'on
le fasse tout de suite oui oh bah oui il
vaut mieux s'en débarrasser il d'accord
je le prends tu vois alors qu'à préparer
tout comme encore grappiller un peu fort
un wind espèce de cartons pas très épais
ouais ouais ça on a ça partout chez soi
bien oui la traîne toujours on va pas
expliquer tout tout de suite
aulas d'abord faire marcher l'appareil
de photo way et ensuite en annexe que le
truc d'accord si tu veux bon alors
suivez-moi très attentif à la paille de
photos je vais le mettre devant moi et
cet appareil de photo va me prendre en
photographie très rapidement comme
impeccable juillet we have a dream je
peux dire quelque chose
oui suivez bien parce que c'est étonnant
1 x fighters xii est que je le fasse
bien tuer
oui 1 2 et 3 pop et voilà regardez on
croit rêver
oui oui ça c'est moi c'est cette chose
là c'est moi qui ai fait en gros au coin
pas à peu près bon et bien comment ça
fonctionne alors voilà c'est là que les
affaires se compliquent légèrement mais
pas tellement les mois vous prenez
d'abord une feuille de carton léger
comme ceci n'est ce pas il faut qu'elles
soient attachés comme cela je pense que
vous voyez très bien
caméra bon maintenant premier point sur
la première feuille vous découpez les
trois côtés d'un rectangle et attention
sur la première feuille vous laisser le
côté du bas sans le découper voulu
laisser intact autrement dit 1 2 et 3
jusque-là pff abc trail est une
explication fabrice 1 astuce c'est sur
cette première page qu'il faut coller la
photo de la personne que vous voulez
photographier ça c'est important ne vous
trompez pas vu pour la première page
deuxième page à peu près la même chose
vous découpez les trois côtés d'un
rectangle en laissant le côté duo
intacte
voyez comment ça s'articule et c'est sur
cette seconde page que vous dessinez
l'objectif de l'appareil de photo au
suprême astuces cette fois-ci vous
glissez l'objectif sous la photo vous
refermez le tout et je vous le fais
doucement maintenant pour que vous
puissiez voir l'articulation
ça glisse comme ça et hop et r vous avez
la photo la gelée fait lentement exprès
pour que vous compreniez le système et
vous que vous puissiez leur faire ça
c'est très beau et puis alors savait
chanter décidé alors au tour 1 le petit
appareil ça on peut faire des
différentes 100 appareils sont assez
simples ou le dessiner avec des crayons
de couleurs ou avec la peinture pinceaux
ça c'est tout ce qu'il faut savoir
dessiner un petit peu mon favori est
comment ça se passe et pas tellement
compliqué bravo à moi je trouve ça bien
amusés à wisekey a mené cette attaque a
raison ça tu en as beaucoup de temps
james pc ou tu verras tu verras je vais
étonner encore plus d'une fois tu sors
avec moi une seconde
ah bon c'est mon tour de sortir non mais
on sort tous les travaux pas d'accord
alors je dis aux gens une fois qu'on ya
des pousses nouvelle logement en fait je
m'en fais des bonnes âmes tout de suite
oui oui oui oui et il laisse un signe
fort
oui bon ça y est à belvis appel ne va
pas tu appelé toutes les semaines
pourquoi c'est pas bien cette place mais
si c'est bon alors par fabrice je te
rappelle le point commun nous te raconte
neuf tous les trois belles belles
pousses monsieur et moi c'est une
histoire nous sommes des choses des
objets des bottes des plantes 1 int et
nous avons chacun une version différente
mais nous avons un point commun ils à
six voies attends je rappelle que moi je
dois découvrir le point commun est tous
nos amis également vous tous ensemble on
essaie de découvrir quel est le point
que vous avez tous en commun va la mort
alors qu'ils commencent et ben moi
toujours
alors moi tu sais ce que je suis je suis
un aigle alors ça me gonfle tu vois je
suis un [ __ ] dire je prends je me mets
de profils tu vois revient en garde tu
vois ce n'est peut-être pas l'envergure
pour les jeunes bien jeu de temps mais
elle se détend mais celle là tu vois je
lui veulent pas sortir ça ne fait rien
c'est la fatigue alors regarde moi
regarde se profile sauvageau un ce
profond crochus ou alors quand je vois
une proie et qui est en dessous de noix
dans la vallée je plonge je fonce craque
jamais serre sur ses ailes
si nous avons ou sur son dos si c'est un
animal qui trotte et je le ramène dans
mon nid d'aigle tu vois là c'est si bien
c'est bien maintenant c'est à moi
fabrice je suis une plume
mais attention pas une plume comme on
peut en voir surtout quand même tension
non je suis une plume en métal au nord
quelquefois à l'extrémité d'un stylo à
j'en ai écrit des choses dans ma vie
tiens quand j'étais petit j'ai écrit des
devoirs de dictée et puis aussi des
cartes postales de l'oeuvre de livres
des poèmes des chansons à j'en ai usé de
l'encore fabrice si je pouvais me
rappeler tout ce que j'ai fait mais là
c'est pas du tout puisque j'étais pas
beaucoup de mémoire fait pas clair
encore j'ai pas que ça à boire alors moi
moi moi je ne suis pas comme tout cancan
non non je ne suis pas un mec joue là
pas du tout je suis une cafetière
oui une bonne grosse gaffe caire
remarque je ne me plains pas de mon sort
on soigne bien haut
on tient bien au chocolat des fois j'ai
même eu très chaud je bous on ne le
réalise pas et je suis tellement content
je suis tellement content le matin quand
je vois arriver toute ma famille le père
la mère les enfants écrit tous en même
temps ça sent bon
et ils tendent leurs tatweer bouaflé en
somme je suis le premier bonheur de la
journée 1
et crois moi je trouve ça bien agréable
oui alors alors oui à thé peut-être bien
agréable mais alors ça pas comme un
dommage que vous ne puissiez pas m'aider
je pense que certains d'entre eux ont
déjà trouvé mais alors moi je cale un
peu alors résumons cafetiers et
ce que tu m'as dit elle et puis alors
bell bell est une plume mais ça ça ça
m'embête parce que tu vois l'histoire de
la plume y ça me saoule un peu mais
entre autres la caf et la ville pour y
avoir la couleur c'est tout noir le car
il est gris tout noir oui mais alors je
vois combien pour la plus longue alors
qu'il serait nous allons non non non je
pense a pas de très bon aloi
est ce que met on a un aigle qui se
caractérise un aigle c'est son sens et
serge anciens la caf hier matin vers 8 h
ier avant bravo label la plume aussi
[Musique]
mauvais abbas et c'est mon jeu et le
cadre de vie chez mon jeu je de pouce
moussu assez d'accord andré pousse
moussu exactement alors tu es d'accord
et bien travaillé olaru la wii
j'ai atteint mon p cette fois ci je vais
essayer j'ai un mot difficile encore
oula je prends mon crayon oui oui comme
d'habitude ton crayon je vais écrire là
bas au tableau au tableau voilà aussi
assez bien c'est parce qu'il m'a préparé
car des syrtes files ou alors c'est un
mot andy l'être encore agréable alors le
premier de la première lettre un cetain
ces célébrations assez voilà le fait
alors après tu fais huit petits points
ou une petite raie comme tu veux un de
rock 5 6 7 8 et la dernière let's et 1 x
un xxs voilà à rien ne dit pas
grand-chose à dakar
alors je pose le cul à tu poses des
questions comme d'habitude et moi je te
réponds est ce que c'est est ce que
c'est un homme célèbre rhône ou au non
pas du tout non pas dans une femme
célèbre non plus en plus mais un homme
d'une femme née un homme et une femme
non voilà c'est un animal
non non plus c'est pas un animal c'est
pas un animal n'est pas un animal est ce
que est ce que c'est je sais pas moi est
ce que c'est un métal non ils n'ont pas
mis talent c'est pas un métal est ce que
ce pourrait être une fleur
non non c'est pas une couleur un une
couleur non non non non vous
m'embarrasser souhaitait que je t'aide
prentice que je peux t'aider
alors la cinquième l'être oui la
cinquième la vie voilà ça dans les
milieux oui c'est un thé comme tout
content
ap voilà tout cas voilà maintenant tu
devrais trouver
oui comme c'est comme ça c'est facile
est ce que c'est une fleur non c'est pas
une fleur je t'ai déjà dit une plante à
ces aspects un as pas loin c'est pas
loin en tout cas c'est paul n'est pas un
arbre assas et c'est peut-être ça c'est
certain at six ans dans le doubs la cua
ferry est ce que est ce que c'est très
utile
ah oui est ce que moi je m'en sers bah
oui oui est-ce que tu t'en sers à moi
non
de nombreux mois m'en bats les jean
louis borloo est très très en vue tout
le temps pratiquement tout le temps est
ce que par exemple je m'en sers chez moi
oh oui
est-ce que je m'en sers dans ma voiture
ah oui georges était indispensable
indispensable il ya toi est ce que dans
ma voiture c'est quelque chose qui qui
fait rage à diriger le temps
spécialement danser c'est lent c'est
très clair est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui tourne mal
non non non ça tourne dans la voiture
c'est tourner rabat 6 à toi tout rebâtir
l'étroite ourabah typhon faroun oui ça
tourne ça tours en bas alors si cet acte
par un 6 1
est-ce que c'est près d'une roue à ses
provinces mm c'est très près de la route
ah oui c'est bizarre parce que je sais
que c'est ces blancs fcg blanchet chez
doit rechercher
c'est tout ce que la couleur concept là
sur la rouge penserait bien une chose
mais ça n'irait pas là pourquoi bas
parce que si ça commence par un c c'est
fini pour moi je pensais pour être tu
pas du tout mais ben oui eh ben ça y est
tu as trouvé et c'est du caoutchouc toi
tu fais des erreurs comme non parce que
ça dépend comme ça caoutchouc à chinon
karim haggui lui ai dit c'est pas un mix
à la fin comment alors m'excuseras sega
watts route
woods et enfin sochaux s'est avait cassé
avec un sim écrivez ça comme ça au cas
où tshomba enfin j'aurais dû me rappeler
avait pour caoutchouc c'est la même
lettre aux deux bouts qui est pourtant
facile à raismes lettre aux deux bouts
risque au moins tu sais où ça se trouve
le caoutchouc a bien sûr quand j'étais
jeune je vivais dans une forêt d'arbres
à caoutchouc
mais au début achève sujet tu es bête je
croyais que c'était des feuilles ou les
fruits étaient en caoutchouc et puis
j'ai vu des hommes venir faire des
grandes entailles dans les troncs dans
les troncs d'arbres et et il en sortait
un l'équipe qui ressemblait à du lait et
on a expliqué que c'était ça qui
devenait du caoutchouc et du caoutchouc
avec les vrais arrivé avec 2 c à chaque
bout c'est vrai sa maman est ce que tu
pourrais me dire comment s'appelle
l'arbre qui donne le caoutchouc à noah
ça je vais demander à touques encore
parce que je fais pas ça tu peux me dire
toi je voulais dire toi encore c'est sûr
que je sais ça c'est pas que je sais
c'est pas à dire
vers l'effort et d'hévéa vous avez du
caoutchouc et non pas le caoutchouc qui
est une autre plante bon c'est pas mal
on
je suis doué oui c'est vrai écoute par
les chutes en demi mondaine
un beau matin mamie
[Musique]
le reste j'ai copié sont dispo mais là
je suis à vous pour tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo peut-être vers l'avant un beau si
je ne la trouble est pas là tu toi je
dois me concentrer
j'écris une carte postale à londres oui
j'en vois une affectueuse passé à la
nièce du mandarin ming ma chère amie
perles de rosée vraiment oui un coup
d'oeil attention bandits dont tu l'as
fait donc aux seins nus l'ipa ne lis pas
oui enfin je vais te dire de toute façon
même si je disais je comprendrais pas
très date j'ai vu tu écrit en chinois
ont maintenant envoyé aux antilles cgt à
pékin la semaine dernière alors oui
j'avais cru apercevoir
c'est curieux c'est vraiment les avions
alors ça n'existe pas je lui même pas
mais alors pas du tout que l'on mette ma
parole en doute à ne sourit pas à
briller je souris forme où je t en prie
je le vois dans ce rire je le connais
c'est petit sourire en coin fabrice tu
n'es pas un ami tu es un faux frère il
faudrait peut-être de fournir des
preuves exhibé mes tickets de transport
je ne sais plus voilà pas contre je peux
te montrer un cadeau que m'a fait perdre
deux rosés cette plume que j'ai piqué
sur mon chapeau le ma chère amie arraché
aux 6,1 au moment où nous allions
définitivement nous quitter elle en
pleurant
à ce propos tout comme toi qui est du
coup tu ne trouves pas que c'est joli
alors oui c'est très joli mais elle me
va beaucoup mieux qu'elle
oui parce que c'est une question de
couleur orange ne pas fait pour le blond
ou des perles de rosée à des chevaux si
claire s'y plaire si freezes si soyeux
alors fabrice avec ces détails tu me
crois maintenant
ben oui oh oui alors oui sûrement brut
et meftah mais nous ne savons pas ce que
la méfiance est un poison de la raison
qui m'agace mais jamais ça je ne peux
pas supporter je vais m'en aller
bon je ne reviendrai jamais alors voyons
bel bel adieu à brix adieu au mans fin
mais c'est ridicule ne t'en va pas comme
ça enfin les enfants nous n'est pas
fâché voilà la vérité c'est comme elle
me raconte des histoires ça on s'en est
aperçu vous doutez bien qu'elle n'a
jamais mis les pieds en chine
enfin est-ce que vous avez déjà vu des
chinois avec des cheveux blonds et
frisés avec des grands chapeaux avec des
plumes ou scala wasquehal a imaginé ça
elle aime tellement nous raconter ses
voyages en imagination qu'elle reviendra
certainement la prochaine ouverture pour
te consoler tout en tout cas je vais
prendre une photo tu veux d'accord et au
delà en mandarin comme elle a maintenant
elle va le faire tout de suite avec
l'appareil de photo de tout à l'heure ok
allez bon alors l'appareil de photo que
vous connaissez le même exactement je
vais m'en servir pour photographier tout
cancres en tout cas encore sifflé oui
j'ai très bien regarde bien dans la
lumière oui regarde-moi voilà tu me
regardes la à je suis bien là oui
attention tu es 1 2 et hop
et voilà au assad a pas de mal
ça commençait bien regarder le résultat
le voici
oh mais c'est tout quand il est superbe
et magnifique
vous pouvez faire exactement la même
chose avec la photo d'un trauma pas de
votre maman votre frère de l'auteur d'un
ami n'importe qui cela fera plaisir et
voulait surprendre avec ce petit système
petit tout près facile ça vu comment on
fait tout à l'heure parfait alors amusez
vous bien
et à très bientôt au revoir
[Musique]